ومن جهه قال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
التونسي بلحسن اليحياوي في مقابله مع
الجزيره انه من غير الانصاف بحق ضحايا
القوله ان العمليات التي قضوا فيها كانت
عمليات ارهابيه مفتعله وانه لا توجد دوله
تضحي بابنائها مهما كانت رديئه وافقت
تعبيره
اعتقد اننا سوف المجرم في حق الضحايا
الذين ذهبوا الشهداء الذين دفعوا بارواحهم
ودماءهم في هذه العمليات الارهابيه حين
نقول ان هذه العمليه الارهابيه مفتعله كيف
نتحدث عن عمليات ارهابيه مفتعله ونحن
خسرنا خلال هذه العمليات افرادا من الجيش
الوطني وافرادا من قوات الامن والسياسيين
مرموقين ومواطنين عزيزين سيمكن الحديث عن
استيعال ليست هناك اي دوله في العالم يمكن
ان تسمح لنفسها بقتل ابناء شعبها مهما
كانت هذه الدوله قميئه ومهما كانت هذه
الدوله رديئه
كما قال اليحياوي انه لم تحدث محاولات
لتطوير الجهاز الامني بما يلائم حاله
الانتقال الديمقراطيه التي شهدتها تونس بل
انه شهد محاولاتي لتطويعه بحسب وصفه
لم تحدث محاوله فعليه لاصلاح الجهاز
الامني حتى لوائم حاله الانتقال
الديمقراطي اولا في تونس وحتى تمكين من
ادوات التي يمكن ان يشتغل بها بفاعليه على
العكس من ذلك وضعت محاوله تطبيع هذا
الجهاز الامني كما هناك هذه الروايات او
السرديات التي تتعلق بوزير الداخليه
الاسبقا وايضا هناك روايات التي تتعلق
بالجهاز السري لحركه النهضه او الجهاز
الخاص لحركه النهضه الذي اخترق الداخليه
واخترق مفاصل الامن التونسي واصبح يطوع او
يستعمل اله الامن التونسي لخدمه افراضه
ولخدمه مصالحه بل وايضا للتغطيه على بعض
المخالفات حتى لا نقول الجرائم التي حدثت
في تونس